こぉーー
おーーーーー
んちには、はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん
火なんてもう日常で
よく使われるものなんですよ
料理をするときも火
焚き火をするときも火
花火をするのも火
火、火、火
もう どこを見ても日常には
火があふれています
って 火ってほんとに危険で
あの 熱いんですよ  火傷しちゃいます
ていうことで今回はこちら
これが頭、これが手
下、上着
防火服を買ってきました
で この防火服ってなにかと言いますと
なんか 火から身を守れるらしいんですよ
「火を防ぐ」と書いて防火服
なんで もうこれを被ってると
もう 僕は多分ね  火傷しないんすよね
お、すごい！すごい！
僕の声 聞こえますか？ すごい！！
中がすごいぞ  これ
完全になんか燃えなそう
もう燃える要素がなさそうです
「No.2」って書いてありますね
ちょっとなんとかして
手に入れたんですけど
火事のときに助けに
行ったりするときの  あの
火から身を防ぐ服なんで
これを履いていれば多分
どんな火の中でも
無事に行けるんじゃないか
という気がします
なんでちょっと着てみましょう
うわっ
うわっすごい 硬い硬い
ちょー硬い
うわー きつ
え 待って 俺そんなに首が長くないんだよ
え 待って俺そんなに首…
わぁーっ！
そんなに首 長くないんだけど
わー
おー すごいすごい
はい！
すげー がちもんだなー
で 今回ですね  ちょっと
防火服って…
いや 燃えないのは知ってます
隙間がひとつもない
これだけ素晴らしい服なんですけども
本当に燃えないのかどうか
ちょっと ほんとに
ちゃんと検証していきたいと思います
いや 燃えたら困るんですけど
どんな感じなんだろうって
火の中にこれで行ったら
どういう感じになんのかな
っていうのを ちょっと
今回 試してみようと思います
ちょっと花火をたくさん買いました
でも花火って熱いから
きれいな服(?)で行くとやっぱ
あっちっちってなるんで
防火服を着ることによって
もう熱くなく きれいな花火を
浴びることができるのではないか
ていうわけで今回
花火マンになれるという
素敵な体験をしていこうと思います
やっていこうと思います
GO !!
（あははははっ）
（えっ）
あっ
暑っ！暑い！
みなさん！
真似する人はいないと思うんですけど
一応ちゃんと大家さんの許可を取って
安全を確保したうえで
行っております
断じて 火は危険なので
真似はしないでください
はい！では早速 花火を
受けてみたいと思います
待って ほんとに怖い ほんとに怖い
いや でも大丈夫なんでしょ？
だって 火から守るものじゃん
これで だって俺…
燃えたら
あかんよ？
【はじめの激しい咳】
あっつい！
【ED】